foreign
in New York hey John welcome to the show
hey guys big fan of the Cheryl hi John
hi Rachel how are you today we're doing
great thanks for giving us a call how
can we help
all right I have a tough one okay I have
170 000 remaining ballots on my 15-year
fixed mortgage okay 2.0 percent rate so
it's a great rate
financial advisor and accountant insist
I should not pay it off as they all do
however I have about 170 000 in savings
the problem is I skipped the baby step
and I have no College savings for the
kids
okay
if I pay it off
I have no other debt I can immediately
start that so I did skip that 80 step
what's your mortgage paid off 170 sorry
no what do you pay every month in your
mortgage
principle of interest is about 2600.
okay how old are you including the
property tax
of 11
and five okay okay and household incomes
about 400. oh nice okay okay can I tell
you what I'm doing in my house
yes sir
um if I have a 12 year old and a
six-year-old
and if I was in your exact exact same
boat
and I had 170 000 in savings
I would pay my house off before the end
of the day is over
you know they I've always gotten the
yeah I love it I've always gotten the
advice that God willing I can continue
to work and when they start college I'd
pay for that out of my earnings
so I never really
you know started anything up yeah with
the anticipation that I would hopefully
pay this off
absolutely yep
if I pay it off though emergency fund is
gone so I should probably wait a few
months to get that yeah I was gonna say
don't cash it all out that's including
emergency funds yeah yeah I think so
don't do that that would
yeah it keeps keep three months and then
yes and then but write a big check
tonight I mean like have have a level of
it to be like okay we're we're getting
there and yes what you're saying with
your income yeah with your income level
um obviously depending on where your
kids go to school because they all won't
be in school together at the exact same
time that you may be able to cash flow
it completely uh just off of your income
but the question is yeah will you will
you have that
that same level of income in 10 years
let me do this here's some back of the
napkin math okay I'm just using my cell
phone calculator here if you take that
twenty six hundred dollars that you pay
every month
um and multiply it by 12. that's 31 000
a year you're sending not including your
taxes okay
your child is 11. is that what you said
your oldest yes okay so it's seven years
until they go to college
so if I just take Thirty one thousand
dollars times seven that's 218 that's
220 000 bucks
that you can have by not changing your
life in any shape form or fashion just
continuing to pay your mortgage
see what I'm saying yeah that's not cash
flowing that's just if you just kept
making your mortgage payment and stuck
it in a in a zero-sum I mean a zero
percent earning checking account
you still you'd still be way ahead of
most parents
so you feel you know do this in two
steps do a big chunk build the emergency
fund up get it to three months and then
finish it off yeah otherwise you're
going to write 170 000 check and you're
gonna go screaming down Manhattan
Boulevard tonight so happy and then
tomorrow morning your air conditioner is
going to break
and then okay you're not gonna be happy
anymore
but the fact that it's a it's a good
rate and it's two percent and you know
it's a it's an attractive mortgage so to
speak that has no bearing whether my
rate's two percent or five percent it
really doesn't yeah and that's what
makes us weird this is why this is where
we're different than majority of a
financial advisor or a tax Pro out there
or at least ones that we don't recommend
at Ramsay but the the norm out there is
that they're playing a math game John so
on the math side could you invest that
mortgage payments you know or uh or keep
the mortgage and not have you know have
a low interest rate I mean all the the
math game that is played in that
industry like there's a there I like we
have brains like we see it we're like
that I get what they're saying where you
could take this chunk of money and
invest it and you could make more in the
market versus what you're you know
having to pay an interest on your house
all that like mathematically
there's a yeah like I get it that could
happen but yeah but John like what what
Freedom does to you and what peace does
to you when you don't owe anyone
anything
changes the game you're in you're in
downtown New York
uh no Suburban New Jersey okay think
back to 30 months ago
I Rachel and I were in downtown
Manhattan when they came out of Broadway
and said Broadway is closed until
further notice as covet was kicking off
we were in there in March I think March
yeah we had a big work events that we
were doing and we were all down there
yeah all the Ramsey personalities and we
were literally there yeah go back to
that moment and imagine not having a
house payment
do you give do you give a crap what the
interest rate is back then no
not really no and then the idea of or
the age-old saying of cash is king and
you know holding cash and having more
than your emergency fund and just
sitting on it while you have the
mortgage
that we that's a fallacy in your opinion
right it's like cash is King but I have
debt so you're solving for Freedom right
you're solving for freedom
and all when you have when you have debt
and you've got savings all you're doing
is holding the bank's money for them
it's not your money because you owe it
correct yeah so you have cash is King
but you don't have cash you've got their
money just in your account so I would
just give it to them like what is Happy
Gilmore say just
send them home just send them out just
oh man hey congratulations my brother
90 days you're free
appreciate it that's it I know well done
John you've done a fantastic a fantastic
job absolutely incredible and yeah and
that and that's what's interesting about
what we what we encourage you guys to do
is again debt is so normal and people
play the math game over and over and
over and over and over and what's not in
the math game is risk what's in the math
game is not fear what's not in the math
game is sleeping at night what's not in
the math game is not owing anyone
anything and having literally no one
that has their name on your paycheck I
mean there is just something to be said
that can't be put in a formula
but we are as human beings like our soul
who we are and how we function
there's a lot there that again a tax Pro
isn't always going to just sit down and
and help you have those conversations
well I'm always just oh this is hard man
but I always want to ask somebody when
they're giving advice
do you stand to benefit from this advice
right and that's why I appreciate
calling us we're just a neutral third
party out here on the airwaves and I'll
tell you what I'm gonna do in my house
right I'm actively working to set myself
up to be in the position that John is
yeah right for that very reason and my
interest rate's almost identical to his
it's it's basically nothing right yeah
um and it's not about the interest rate
it's about absolutely being free
and here's the great thing too if you
want a mortgage again after you pay it
off you can always go yeah if you like
miss it and you're like oh we really
want that organs to pay it back
we're gonna go back and get one your
wife's gonna tell you hey have a candle
at dinner say I have a hard thing to I
need to tell you he's going to think
what is it she'll say I missed the
mortgage dismiss that mortgage I miss
all that money that 2600 just leaving